- Hello, the internet, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
Welcome to
"The Super Slow Show."
Dan, when we were
coming up with ideas
to do on the spin rig,
we thought we couldn't
leave out our powder paint
on an air bag
experiment.
Love an air bag,
love powder paint.
We're gonna start
with one air bag.
and probably get
carried away
and escalate
beyond our means.
The camera's gonna be
whipping around,
a thousand frames
a second,
- shall we go on?
- Yes, we shall,
absolutely.
( music playing )
Dan: Ooh! It's nice to
be back on the spin rig.
- Gav: Yes, it is,
love a spin rig.
- Dan: Love this thing.
- Okay, are we ready?
- I'm ready.
All right, three,
two, one.
( popping )
- Both: Ooh!
- Gav: Oh, yes.
- See it goes right through?
- Dan: Yeah, that's cool,
It's like it's being blown
around more by the spin rig.
Gav: Oh, look at the cloud
coming in.
It's gonna get us.
Dan: Run through it,
run through it!
( coughing )
It was a mistake.
- All right let's
watch it back.
- ( Dan laughs )
- Real good view.
- Yeah.
This lens is nice because
the world is in focus.
Dan: It's like flying around
one of those massive clouds.
Gav: It is, it's like
a time lapse with a big cloud,
but you're in a plane.
Dan: Yeah, isn't it?
'Cause you're not sitting
all around it.
Gav: Now we get to see
the camera get through.
Dan: Into the eye
of the storm.
( both imitate
explosion sounds )
- Gav: Cool, that's cool.
- Dan: It's in for flying
around, getting launched.
Gav: You see, it's still
going up.
And there we go.
Dan: And there's the air-bag,
we're out.
Shall we put
four on?
- Four?
- Four different colors.
Four.
So, four airbags,
four different colors
all around the thing.
I think that would
be wise.
Should we stagger them
so it's one after
the other...
- Yeah.
- And they all go off
at the same time.
Otherwise the front one
will block the camera.
Yeah, okay.
So, it's all good
on me this time.
Gonna have to
set one off at a time.
What's your difference
between the airbags.
Uh, complete guess.
Oof, good luck.
Cheers, yeah.
Three, two, one,
go!
- ( popping )
- Oh, geez!
- What a mess.
- That is a mess.
And you can't even
see the camera.
No, you can't.
Flipping heck.
- Huh.
- Hm.
Huh.
Dan: Camera can't see anything.
Gav: Whoa! What am I looking at?
Dan: I guess the airbags
got off already.
Gav: It's like the inside
of a storm.
( Dan laughs )
Gav: Do you remember that scene
at the end of "Twister."
Yeah, that Bill Paxton
is, like, inside the tornado.
Dan: Yeah, yeah.
Gav: Looks like that.
( slow motion
explosion sounds )
Yeah.
So, what we've
done there
is basically get
a spin rig...
- Yeah.
- and span it up,
time it perfectly
- so that it's all
opposite things...
- Yeah.
- Right, and then just gone,
"Nah."
- ( laughter )
You can't see it.
So, I reckon four,
but opposite sides
of this spin rig.
- Gav: Yeah.
- With less paint so
it just sort of
clearer definition
between the explosions.
This is the opposite side
four times,
in time with
the camera.
Yeah?
And you're thumb is tired
from the last time you did it,
- so it's actually.
- Yeah, I've got lactic
acid build up for sure.
- In the thumb.
- In the thumb, yeah.
You should play more
video games.
Maybe so.
- Right.
- Three, two, one.
( explosions )
Gav: Oof! Huh! ( laughs )
Was that the right one?
Yeah. I think so.
- All right.
- Wait, one, two,
three-- yeah, it was.
It's just confusing
because it's opposite.
It's weird that all
the clouds just
become weird.
Like, there's no
color in that.
- Dan: It's weird isn't it?
- Gav: Is it like mixing to
white like light would?
- Dan : I don't know.
- Gav: That doesn't make
any sense.
It's like the opposite
of liquid paint,
it just turns
to vomit,
this turns to
like white.
It just turns
into a sneeze.
- Yeah.
- Let's have a look
and see what...
Dan: Viewing stations.
( slow motion explosion
sounds )
Gav: It's impossible to know
what's going to happen.
- Dan: Buh... boom?
- ( Gav laughs )
Gav: Oh, yeah, easy.
We are rubbish at this,
aren't we?
So now it's just
red is left.
Dan: Is it?
Or isn't it?
Gav: What we've done here
is we've confused ourselves.
Made a big mess.
A big confusing puff.
- Dan: Oh, there it is!
- Gav: I see some red.
Dan: I was still quite--
it's still an interesting shot
- when it goes through.
- Gav: Yeah.
Ah, man, you and I
were coughing at this point.
Feel we were quite
ambitious.
Got some good stuff,
but also a lot of it
just didn't work.
A lot of failures.
But even the failed
attempts
still had some
amazing footage.
Like the shot of
the camera coming through
the blue into the red cloud.
It's just so surreal.
It makes me want
to keep watching it
for some reason.
It's true,
I can't really think
of any other way
of getting that footage
other than with
a spin rig
or just flying
a camera through.
Yeah. So hopefully
you enjoy our failures
just as much as our
successes as we do.
Thank you very much
for watching.
Be sure to subscribe
to the "Slow Mo Guys"
and we'll see you
in the very next episode
of "The Super Slow Show."
( explosion sound )
( music playing )
Hello, internet.
Be sure to click here
for the latest updates
on "The Super Slow Show."
Yeah, click over there
and you'll actually
get to see Gavin
get to step up from
behind the camera
and get his hands dirty.
That's true actually,
I had to use soap.
Did you get both
of them dirty?
Both hands.
Unbelievable.
- Well done.
- Yeah, thanks.